hola soy mitchell baker tengo 31 años y
tengo trastorno de ansiedad pero saben
que no me da pena decirlo de hecho casi
podría asegurar que es lo mejor que me
ha pasado porque me hizo la persona que
estoy hoy y hace que esté hoy aquí
además siempre he sido 100% funcional la
ansiedad no es algo que me caracteriza
solo es parte de mí como lo son el color
de mis ojos o mi estatura
llevo 10 años trabajando en relaciones
públicas en revistas de moda y estilo de
vida actualmente soy directora de
relaciones públicas de estilo de efe y
hace tres años lanza catarsis una
plataforma para hablar de salud mental
vale la pena mencionar que no soy
psicóloga y todo lo que van a escuchar
aquí lo he aprendido de mi propia
experiencia y muchas veces la base de
golpes
para empezar hay que entender qué es la
ansiedad la ansiedad es un mecanismo
normal del cuerpo incluso es algo bueno
porque nos avisa que hay un peligro y
manda y el cerebro manda señales a
nuestro cuerpo para que se proteja este
mecanismo se llama lucha o huida y es
heredado de nuestros antepasados en ese
entonces los peligros eran un león que
te iba a atacar una tormenta no por eso
las únicas maneras de protegerte eran
salir corriendo o luchar por esa lucha o
huida si no corría su pelea vas contra
el león te ibas a morir de ahí vienen
los síntomas de la ansiedad o del estrés
el corazón empieza a bombear sangre más
rápido a las extremidades porque son las
necesarias para correr o para pelear por
eso tenemos mareos temblorina hormigueos
la visión borrosa es la reacción a la
dilatación de las pupilas para que entre
más luz la hiperventilación es porque
necesitamos más oxígeno para correr o
para pelear como la digestión en ese
momento no es necesaria la sangre deja
de fluir a esos órganos y por eso nos
podemos sentir mareados con náusea o se
nos seca la boca
seguramente se estarán preguntando por
qué si no me enfrentado a ningún animal
salvaje me he sentido así porque si ya
no hay animales salvajes hoy en día
déjenme decirles que aunque no lo crean
hoy en día tenemos un montón de animales
salvajes las cuentas por pagar la
pandemia las peleas con nuestra pareja
los exámenes etcétera
todos esos son animales salvajes nuestro
cerebro no distingue entre la realidad y
un pensamiento no le importa si es un
tigre o una pandemia este va a
reaccionar igual ante el peligro por eso
nosotros mismos nos podemos hacer tanto
daño alimentando nuestros pensamientos
negativos sentir ansiedad es normal
sin embargo cuando ésta es muy elevada
por tiempos prolongados por situaciones
que no deberían desencadenar la o cuando
empieza a interferir en nuestra vida
podemos empezar a sospechar de un
trastorno por ejemplo es normal sentir
los nerviosos y tener miedos del
coronavirus porque sabemos la razón está
justificado pero
si sentimos muy miedo con niveles super
elevados por mucho tiempo no podemos
dormir empezamos a tener síntomas como
de un ataque de ansiedad o la frecuencia
cardíaca acelerada por ejemplo podríamos
empezar a sospechar de un trastorno
lo más impresionante es que nos hemos
acostumbrado a pensar que es normal
vivir en estado de alerta y con la
ansiedad pero no es así y no tiene nada
de malo pedir ayuda tenemos que empezar
a hablar abiertamente de salud mental ya
normalizar lo si tuvieran dolor en
alguna parte del cuerpo o algún hueso
roto irían al doctor correspondiente es
cierto
no tendría por qué ser diferente con
nuestros tornos mentales y esta ha sido
nuestra labor en catarsis por eso les
quiero contar mi experiencia porque
estoy segura que mientras más hablemos
del tema menos tabúes habrán
desde niña tengo trastorno de ansiedad
aunque en ese momento nadie sabía lo que
era mis papás pensaban que tenían una
niña miedosa insegura y que con el
tiempo se me iba a pasar en ese entonces
mi ansiedad se reflejaba en pensamientos
obsesivos eran ideas que se me metían a
la cabeza y no había poder humano que me
la quitará ojo eran
eran ideas que me generaban un miedo
como si tuvieran león en el frente para
mí pensar que tenía las manos llenas de
microbios era como si tuviera a un león
y estuviera peleando contra él sentía de
verdad lo mismo algunos otros ejemplos
de esa época eran que tenía apendicitis
no salir al recreo porque me daba miedo
que me dejaré el camión lavarme las
manos excesivamente
en no poder dormir obviamente el estar
pensando no puedo dormir no puedo dormir
no puedo dormir hacía que de verdad no
durmiera pasé meses sin poder dormir
conforme iba conociendo el mundo iba
creciendo y madurando los miedos iban
junto a mí ya no me era suficiente lo
que mis papás me dijeran ya no me era
suficiente que me dijeran que me
llevaron al doctor a decirme que no
tenía apendicitis
tenía 14 años tenía muchísima ansiedad
muchísimos miedos y mis papás me
llevaron a mi primera cita con el
psiquiatra yo salí de ahí tomando prosas
que eso es un antidepresivo y rivotril
que es un ansiolítico ambas medicinas
controladas por psiquiatras y que no se
deben tomar jamás jamás por su propia
cuenta y con la indicación de ir al
psicólogo ahora entiendo que en ese
momento era lo único que se les ocurre a
mis papás a hacer porque se conocía
mucho menos del tema pienso que si esto
hubiera sucedido hoy en día tal vez se
hubieran empezado con algún otro tipo de
tratamiento a lo mejor alguna terapia
alternativa o alguno oa lo mejor un
psicólogo
es muy fácil evadir las cosas y solo
apoyarnos de las medicinas a final de
cuentas estas si cumplen su prometido y
nos quitan esos síntomas tan horribles
que nos hacen sentir que vamos a tener
un ataque al corazón pero son como un
curita nada más cubren la herida pero no
la sanan no llegan a la raíz de la
ansiedad y yo vivía así muchos años
aunque iba generalmente a terapia yo
solita me sea tonta porque no tocaba el
tema que verdaderamente me da miedo
parece entonces yo tenía una sola idea
obsesiva y esa misma idea obsesiva no me
dejaba en paz era vuelta en mi cabeza
tras vuelta tras vuelta nervio y sobre
todo era ya un miedo que tenía tan
profundo y tan en mi interior que me
impedía relacionarnos con los demás ya
veces me impedía pero hacer ciertas
cosas en mi vida pero me daba tanto
miedo hablar de eso que sólo lograba
hacerlo cuando estaba en un ataque de
ansiedad cuando estaba en un ataque de
ansiedad hagan de cuenta que yo vomitaba
lo que me estaba pasando lo que estaba
en mi cerebro porque nada más necesitaba
que necesitaba que me dijeran
cálmate no es cierto cálmate ahorita que
usted es tranquila lo vamos a platicar
cada vez más estaba pidiendo rescates de
emergencia sin llegar al fondo de la
situación si alguna vez en sentido así
se van a identificar conmigo que cuando
estamos en ese estado no podemos pensar
claramente no a veces las cosas más
obvias no no lo son para nosotros
evidentemente nuestro cerebro está tan
preocupado por sobrevivir porque tenemos
que sobrevivir que deja de prestar
atención a los detalles y por eso a
veces podemos sentir que perdemos el
piso
yo en ese estado y siempre pongo este
ejemplo podría jurar que el cielo era
verde y yo salía podría salir a la calle
ver el cielo tú me enseñaba las fotos y
yo no te creía hasta que no lograba
llegar a mi centro yo sé que en ese
momento parece que nunca vamos a salir
de esa situación y que siempre nos vamos
a sentir así de mal pero siempre siempre
siempre por el mismo mecanismo de lucha
o huida llegue y regresamos a nuestro
centro y a ver a ver las cosas con
claridad
así pasa los primeros 7-8 años de mi
vida nada más pidiendo rescates cuando
me sentía muy mal de verdad no podía
ahondar en el tema sin embargo me llegó
la primera lección
mi ansiedad solo es una defensa es un
mecanismo de defensa automático de mis
propios problemas qué quiere decir esto
este pensamiento llegaba a mí cuando me
pasaban dos cosas llevaba mucho tiempo
sin sacar mis sentimientos y era como
una olla express que no aguantaba en la
presión o había algo que no estaba
hablando y que estaba evadiendo y
prefería evadir lo porque bien dicen wta
y más vale malo por conocido que bueno
por conocer
cuando cumplí 24 o 25 años
aproximadamente decidí que ya no podía
seguir así por más miedo que me diera
tenía que superarlo porque si no hablaba
del tema y sí no
si no lo superaba si no lo pasaba no iba
a salir adelante en mi vida me voy a
quedar estancada me acuerdo que
administraciones con mi psicóloga de esa
época leíamos en mi juego que vamos a
leer un libro de este tema que tanto te
aterra leíamos un renglón yo le decía
que el profesor vamos a leer dos
renglones o sea dos oraciones y después
hablamos de otro tema porque yo no me
puedo ir de aquí con este mal sabor de
boca son nada más de abrir el libro yo
de nuevo sentía al tigre o al león en
frente de mi me paralizaba pensaba que
si lo hablaba se iba a hacer realidad
cuando pasaba todo lo contrario solo se
iba haciendo más ligero iba descubriendo
que no era verdad
después de unos meses empecé a sentir
empezó a sentir que me quitaba un peso
de encima ese pensamiento esa idea ya no
tenía tanto poder sobre mí ya aprendí la
segunda lección se necesita mucha
valentía para analizar nuestros miedos
más profundos porque es mucho más fácil
evadir las cosas pero si lo hacemos de
alguna u otra forma tarde o temprano
siempre van a salir por más difícil que
sea siempre tenemos que intentar hablar
de nuestros problemas tratarlos y
trabajarlos
durante esos primeros 10 años dejé
varias veces las medicinas por mi cuenta
ojo no lo recomiendo no lo hagan estas
medicinas son muy muy muy controladas y
para dejarlo se tienen que hacer
paulatinamente con ayuda de su
psiquiatra o su doctor no la diferencia
entre un psicólogo y un psiquiatra es
que el psicólogo solo la terapia y
diferentes métodos diferentes tipos y el
psiquiatra es doctor es médico por lo
cual el psiquiatra puede darte medicinas
a través de tan terapia pero
generalmente eso lo hacen los psicólogos
a pesar de que los años siguientes ya no
cargaban con esa ansiedad ya no cargaba
con esa ansiedad y con ese pensamiento
si tenía ansiedad sea siempre mi
respuesta ante todo era la ansiedad yo
no sabía sentir enojo yo no sabía sentir
tristeza cada que llegaba a mí una
situación difícil mi reacción era sentir
ansiedad
y aquí llegó la tercera lección y es que
la ansiedad siempre va a ser parte de mí
pero no puedo dejar que me controle la
ansiedad solo es el mensajero que me
está avisando que hay algo a lo que le
tengo que prestar atención que hay algo
que no está bien pero la ansiedad no es
el mensaje de la ansiedad es el
mensajero
la ansiedad de tantos años me había
dejado debilitada yo pensaba que era
insegura que era miedosa que no sabía
cómo empezar a reconstruir me después
como que después de tantos años de
cargar con un pensamiento o con un miedo
cuando ya no lo tenía me quedé como
vacía no no sabía cómo empezar
me había quedado y de repente mi
ansiedad en este momento se empezó a
reflejar en unos miedos terribles de
perder a los demás no deposite mi valor
y mi poder en los demás el simple hecho
de pensar de pensar en perder a las
personas me hacía sentir como que tenía
un león no enfrente o sea deje que
familiar es muy tóxico que manipularan
que amigas igual tóxicas me dijeran las
cosas más terribles que me habían dicho
y aun cuando me hacían eso a mí me daba
miedo quedarme sola y dejarlos mi
bienestar y muy sentido y mi ánimo
empezó a depender de los demás tenía muy
clara la razón
porque en mis años de terapia ya me
habían iluminado algunos de mis demonios
pero no sabía cómo superarlo estaba
estancada porque en mi cabeza entendía
perfecto lo que me estaba pasando pero
no podía bajarlo a mi cuerpo no decía ok
ya sé lo que quiero ya sé que necesito
dejar de depender de los demás ya sé que
mi ansiedad es una respuesta a muchas
otras cosas pero y qué hago no ya lo sé
y ahora cómo lo hago me sentía estancada
en un laberinto sin salida y entonces
llegó el 2020
este año tan raro y transformador para
todos lo empecé con una de mis peores
épocas de verdad yo tenía de 3 a 4
ataques de ansiedad al día y cuando no
tenía un ataque sentía miedo tristeza
enojo y eso que no había empezado a la
pandemia todavía estaba tan desesperada
que yo quería buscar respuestas en el
exterior yo quería que alguien me dijera
tienes que hacer esto y mañana vas a
estar bien no hay de verdad empecé a
buscar por todos lados fui con chamanes
con brujos me leyeron las cartas de
energía todo y nada más acababa más
confundida porque cada quien me decía
otra cosa y que en abril ya va a pasar
tal cosa y obviamente nunca pasó nada de
lo que me dijeron cada vez que regresaba
con mi psicóloga me decía deja de andar
buscando tantas opiniones nada más te
están haciendo bolas enfócate en lo que
ya sabes que te funciona y ahí llegó
la cuarta lección y creo que es una de
las más importantes y es yo obtengo las
respuestas en mi interior kai qin tienen
las respuestas en su interior no depende
de nadie más esto es muy fuerte porque
quiere decir que tienes que salir de tu
papel de víctima y trabajar en ti pero
también es muy iluminador porque también
es una respuesta hasta cierto punto a
dejar de depender de los demás de
hacerte cargo tú mismo de tus propios
problemas sabía que mi meta era vivir
tranquila y sentir que sin sentir que
necesitaba de alguien sin sentir
miedo de perder a los demás pero de
nuevo no sabía cómo hacerlo yo decía ok
sí qué bueno eso ya lo sé y ahora no
todos esos que te dicen tú tienes que
ser fuerte y no le hables a los demás y
buscan nuevos amigos y buscan nuevas
cosas y yo ok pero como si cuando lo
intentó siento como que un tigre se está
acercando no només no me es fácil no
entiendo cómo lo puedo hacer
entonces decidí cambiar el enfoque en
vez de enfocarme
en alejarme de los demás bien ok solo
por hoy no voy a hablar con tal persona
solo por hoy me voy a relacionar
diferente con tal persona dije yo quiero
estar tan llena de cosas y tan inspirada
con lo que a mí me gusta que poco a poco
voy a dejar de necesitar a los demás no
quiero trabajar en alejar a los demás
quiero trabajar en mí y automáticamente
pues va a haber menos espacio para los
demás solo van a caber las personas que
verdaderamente necesita verdaderamente
se alinean con lo que estoy pensando con
lo que quiero hacer en ese momento
y poco a poco empecé a hacer eso se me
acuerdo que iba a una clase de yoga con
muchas penas porque no sabía hacer nada
no esté
tenía una agenda con mi psicóloga en
donde ponía que día iba a probar otra
cosa qué día iba a buscar un curso de
tal y así iba poco a poco hasta que
llegó la pandemia
llegó la pandemia nos encerramos
y
tuve el tiempo para tuve tiempo para
dedicarme lo 100% a mí para leer de
cosas que nunca había podido para tomar
cursos en línea y de verdad es increíble
como cuando estás como alineada con tus
contigo mismo y con lo que quieres hacer
las cosas solitas
solitas se van dando empecé a conectar
con personas que nunca antes en mi vida
hubiera creído personas que conocía de
hace tiempo pero que pudimos generar
proyectos de verdad algo que me
impresionó muchísimo es que llevaba años
intentando conocer gente nueva ya hacer
proyectos nuevos y cuando podía salir a
la calle no lo hice después solo
encerrado y cuando hay gente que puede
solo encerrada y de manera digital que
pude conectar y conocer gente y eso me
parece increíble
no podrás decir que yo estoy curada
de hecho ni siquiera creo que hay algo
de lo que me tenga que curar porque no
lo considera una enfermedad lo único que
les puedo decir es que ya tengo las
herramientas para no dejarme caer o
salir del hoyo más fácil más rápido y
creo que es una de las claves más
importantes para cualquier persona que
esté en este trayecto no deje entender y
tener herramientas para salir más rápido
no buscan estar bien no buscar estar
bien todo el tiempo porque eso es
imposible siempre hay cosas complicadas
en esta vida
no hay nada más valiente que trabajar en
nosotros mismos yo sé que da miedo da
miedo y de avergüenza a veces aceptar
que no estamos bien o que no estamos tan
bien como los demás creen pero la mejor
manera de ser felices e siendo honestos
con nosotros mismos no tiene por qué
darnos pena pedir ayuda profesional o
hablar de nuestra salud mental con
nuestras personas más cercanas habemos
muchos que estamos pasando por lo mismo
y por lo menos en catársis siempre
tendrán un espacio donde no se van a
sentir juzgados muchas gracias